hold it hold it hold it hold it
I don't anymore that playing that Elfi
I've been married six weeks and my wife
says you mustn't play Elfi anymore when
I come on you got to play when I grow
too old two three
that's an ad-lib I really put him out up
there look now we're just uh my wife and
I we're just a plain couple plain as a
pair of old slippers and about as
interesting and that's why I feel so
comfortable introducing another average
couple real homebodies de Bono's Sonny
and sure
you know something Michael is really
right we are home bodies I mean you
never take me anyplace well sure that's
that's cuz you're complaining you in
there having anything to wear well I
haven't yeah and you're wearing it cards
you were supposed to just come out here
and say the nominees for the best song
are right that's what I'll do okay I'm
saying that now all right they are Ben
from Ben music by Walter sharp and
lyrics by Don Black come follow follow
me from the little arc music by Fred
Carlin lyrics by Marsha Carmen marmalade
molasses and honey from the life and
times of judge Roy Bean music by Maurice
Jarre lyrics by Marilyn and Alan Bergman
the morning after from the Poseidon
Adventure music and lyrics by Al kasha
and Joel Hirshhorn strange are the ways
of love from the stepmother yeah
stepmother I thought said father for a
second music by Sammy fain lyrics by
Paul Francis Webster and the winner is -
no I'll do it
want the opening no I'll do it with my
finger the winners are Al kasha and Joel
Hirsch one for the morning after
like well I can say is that I'm in a
state of shock this is a fantastic
surprise and I just want to thank Lionel
lumen for giving us the opportunity and
Ronald neem and Irwin Allen special
thanks for - happy --got day for
believing in us from the beginning thank
you thank you I wanna give my thanks to
her whanau and the producer and Ronald
lien and of course Lionel Newman and a
special thanks to happy --got day and
most of all to the Academy
I'm very extremely grateful and you made
two people very happy in Brooklyn
tonight rose and Irving caches so thank
you